what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i'm going to be talking about a
slight disagreement that i have with the
manosphere um
i don't pretend to know everything this
is just from my anecdotal experience
so if you guys are going to come into my
comments
and um say that i'm just emotional
you can i don't really care you can
leave that comment like i really don't
care
but but i'm just telling you this is
from my anecdotal experience so
this is just one disagreement i have um
can 50 50 relationships work and
my voice keeps cracking today i don't
know why can 50 50 relationships work
and can a relationship work where the
woman makes
more than the man um i've seen a lot of
comments
saying that like a woman can't respect a
man that makes
less than her or a woman can't be with a
man
um that makes like less money than her
but i've actually i've seen enough
relationships in marriages
that work where the woman
um makes
more than the man but what i have
noticed like what sets it apart
is if the woman like actually respects
him as a man
even though she makes more money um so
i've seen
like i have a a aunt that's been married
to her husband and they're like the
cutest couple oh my god
they're so cute and she
like she's always made the money he's
always like moved for her job
and she like she's in charge of all that
and
like but the reason i see it working is
because they're both like very
respectful of each other and they both
um i don't know they both have the same
sense of humor and they're super cute
and they're like genuinely like top five
i would say cutest couples i've seen
that have been married for 20 plus years
and don't like look like they want to
kill each other
um and then it also leaves like women if
like a woman happens to be super
productive and good at her job like
she's just supposed to make less money
what what do you want her to do um
so that's just like my opinion though um
i've definitely seen it work i think it
can work i think the important part is
that both partners like respect each
other
and um like the woman doesn't see like
the guy as lesser than
just because he makes less money than
her because in that relationship he
brought a lot to the relationship like
he helped a lot with the kids
he um was super respectful he's very
funny like he had a lot of qualities
more than just money
um so yeah let me know in the comments
if you guys agree or you disagree don't
forget to subscribe to the channel
i'm gonna keep playing around with this
like unedited just talking about random
things format so let me know
if you guys like this leave a comment
let me know and i will talk to you guys
next time